hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
let me tell you something you do not
need
deposits to buy houses
most people think you've got to save up
loads of money buy a house
rent it out in this video i'm going to
show you exactly
how you can acquire properties using a
strategy called lease option agreements
i've done dozens and dozens of these
myself my students are now doing these
and you can do it too so do me a favor
before i show you around this house
before you see exactly
how this has been structured and
financed smash the like button
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss a future video
let's go around have a look and i'll
show you what's what so this is a big
old house in huddersfield
and this was actually acquired by one of
my students jl spooner who i'm going to
introduce you to
how's it going jl hi how are you so this
property
like just give me an idea if you were to
have bought this property just the
traditional way
how much money i mean what's the
property worth right now
290 000 okay so you need about 25
percent
that's gonna be 25 grand approximately
per 100 so you have 25
50. so you think about 75 plus legals
plus stamp duty so realistically to
buy a house like this you're gonna need
about a hundred thousand pounds of cash
how much money did you put into this
house well i didn't have to put down a
deposit or stamp duty
i did pay a few months rent up front so
i ordered all in all i put about six
thousand pounds into the property which
you paid for
via through sourcing properties i
actually got it through sourcing
uh properties and then i used that money
to
to pay for this place so let me get this
right so you packaged you found some
deals not this house
but you found some other houses
negotiated them yes
sold them to investors did that a few
times made six thousand pounds
you then use that six thousand pounds to
acquire
this property now this is not rent to
rent
no you're actually on the on the on the
title bids not as an owner
but as someone who has the option to buy
it yes okay well we're going to talk you
through exactly how this works how it's
structured but firstly do you want to
give us a little talk
[Music]
so this property then so we did have a
lot of reception rooms
a lot of bedrooms um but what jl's done
is she's turned the reception rooms
like this this was a sitting room but
now
it's a bedroom and joe tell me how do
you turn
a reception room into a bedroom you put
a beard in it
right so this was a reception room it
had a chair and stuff like that when you
when you took it on
and all of the reception rooms you're
you've just turned into bedrooms i
literally have
by putting beds in them so that's nice
you've not spent a ton of money on this
stuff
no everything i've spent could actually
be removed so yeah
what do you mean by that i just spent on
furniture right literally just found it
so the house was already in good
condition when you took it on yeah
and another interesting thing is this is
a lease option agreement we wouldn't we
don't we don't advise that you spend
loads of money on a lease option
agreement do we if it's a residential
house generally speaking
so okay talk to me about how many you've
just got this but how many rooms are you
going to rent out
immediately so immediately i'm going to
be renting out four rooms
because i've had to obviously get a
license to get
uh hmm planning as well for hmo um
so at the moment i could only rent out
for the road why for
it because that's legal right
so so to rent out if you're renting at
hmo and you want to rent out four rooms
assuming it's not in an article four
area
you don't need a license to do that you
don't need planning to do that so what
jl's doing is she's immediately renting
out to four people to get some rent
coming in get the money in yeah but then
she's gonna be applying for planning
permission
which you need if there's how many
bedrooms or more
uh if there's seven bedrooms seven
bedrooms or more yeah if there's more
than four you need a license you're
gonna need both
i need both so you're gonna apply for
planning you're gonna have a license
but in the meantime money yes 100 love
it
yeah so this property is going to cash
flow me immediately
right but of course once i get planning
it's going to be like super profitable
right so to begin with day one you're
going to make a bit of money
but then once you've got the planning
licensing it's going to make you a lot
of money
how much cash flow by cash flow we mean
monthly profit after all expenditures
are you expected to make
you know once it's completely done
you've got planning you've done
everything how much cash flow
the the net amount should be a healthy
three thousand pounds three grand a
month yeah yeah hold on
hold on did you hear that three thousand
pounds
yeah a month right that that's financial
freedom
so tell me look like backstory how did
this all kind of get started okay so
originally
i think it was about gosh seven years
ago now plus
um i went to a crash course and i
learned about financial freedom
um and it took me a few years to get my
head around it but eventually i became
financially free
there's a time you had nothing no i
started i actually started
i think i when i went to your course i
was actually on benefits in my council
house
right so i had no i was in debt i had no
money whatsoever
and then i came to a course uh and
learned about financial freedom which is
what you were training
um at the time and became financially
free
few years from then and then
yeah i touched base with you when your
crash course obviously blew up
substantially and um yeah you
gave me the good healthy challenge to
become a millionaire then
now jail's on the academy and is close
to becoming a millionaire
property millionaire but you want to be
a net millionaire yes yes awesome
yes so this property has already gone on
the market
we've got like literally a whole load of
viewings on saturday
jails if you know jl she's good at
getting tenants quick it's my thing so
this has been on the market just a few
days and you've got how many viewings
five five viewings this is going to rent
out so there's more rooms
that we need to rent out so far so yeah
and i like this
yeah the character i know we left the
books we just thought it looks nice
it yeah it does i really like it i'd
live here
rooms are big there's character house is
great
[Music]
so these are one this is one of the
rooms
that are going to be ready yeah right
nice good so again this property is in
pretty decent condition you've furnished
it
you've not gone high high-end no i
haven't i've gone quite
how much does this furniture cost oh god
you're testing me now samuel
um i think this whole room was probably
about 400.
okay 400 pounds yeah okay so you decent
not really cheap but it looks nice i
mean that's wardrobe
desk chair bed side table and decoration
and life
so what what i really want to know okay
and i think what these guys want to know
is you've got this property what does
that mean got do you own it
how have you structured it what is a
lease option agreement how can we get a
lease option agreement
tell me everything i mean it's really
simple i initially
came to this property because i wanted
to buy it but i ended up buying my house
in huddersfield instead
right so you so so basically sorry but
but we've all got a limited amount of
money
yeah right so people might think i don't
need a free house on a lease option
agreement i've got 100 grand
but that's going to run out absolutely
and it did run out on my house you know
what i mean so i needed
um another lead but i actually because
obviously i had the academy i'm
constantly going back to it
because it's like a toolbox i'm able to
see what strategy
works for my next evolution where i am
next now i knew i put a lot of money
into green heads into huddersfield
but i still wanted more things to do
right so i ended up trying to get this
as
a rent to rent because i saw it up on
the market for rent and again rent to
rent for anyone doesn't know
is when you you would pay the landlady
yeah a guaranteed rent yeah
maybe a thousand pounds you might rent
it for four thousand pounds
that leaves you with three thousand you
might have to pay a thousand pounds on
bills management yeah but then you're
left with two thousand pounds a month
clean profit yes that's right to
remember you don't own it
that's right and i told you specifically
well you said jl look
try to focus on you've done rent to rent
you've done that and you've done it well
and it's
it's what brought you yourself that's
what helped you
get to where you are today but then you
said you know
focus on bigger things but this
opportunity was here the
lady really wanted somebody to take it
over after doing a little calculation
and knowing that i had to get plan an
application
i needed to get a new boiler i needed to
get you know
do up the house i knew i would have had
to put quite a lot of money into the
products
it's quite a big house six grand plus
you know everything else that comes with
it you know
doing it up and you know things like
that so it would have been too
much for me to have just done a rent to
rent for a couple of years anyway
so i then went back to the course went
back to the toolbox and realized okay
well let me suggest
telling her that i'm gonna buy it in
seven years time well that went down a
treat
it worked for both of us like she
actually didn't want to sell it
because she wants to pay down her
mortgage so she just said to me look
pay me 1 500 per month yeah which is
very cheap
which is amazing yeah which is amazing
and you know i'm not gonna i'm i don't
want anything to do with it i just just
pay me every month so
it's right you're paying 1 500 but then
you're gonna rent the rooms out and then
you're gonna get planning and you're
gonna make a nice profit of about three
grand a month all being well
per month but then on top of that
you've got the option to buy it
absolutely in how many years time
seven years for how much for the the
agreed price 290
000. but it's worth 209 000 now yes so
in seven years
yeah it will probably be worth a lot
more
yeah yeah so we are splitting capital
appreciation
fair but i think that's fair yeah and i
thought it was it was attractive so let
me
let me say something interesting okay
when you buy a house as an investment
you buy a house for two reasons okay
number one is to get rent number two
is to gain from capital appreciation on
the house
that's the only two reasons you buy an
investment house full now
what jael's doing is she's getting
capital appreciation for this house and
she's getting ready for this house but
she didn't need to invest the deposit
into the house
because normally to buy a house she got
invested deposit so what jl's done using
this option agreement
strategy issues agreed a monthly fee
she's going to get cash flow she's
agreed an amount to pay down the line
but if the property goes up in value
which she probably will she's going to
get 50
of the capital appreciation and all jl
needed to put down to get this property
was legal fees a bit of furniture a
little bit of rent up front but i guess
you're gonna get that back
you're gonna get that so it's like why
would you
buy a house why would you save up and
put a deposit down when
you don't have to so because jl's
learned these strategies
instead of just buying one house which
is the first house was her council house
yes or two or three or four she can now
buy an unlimited amount of houses which
is why now she's a property millionaire
which is why now she's gonna become a
cash millionaire very soon yeah trump's
stoked
yeah yeah it's unbelievable you would
think
that it's not possible i remember
watching your youtube clips and
sitting there like i'm gonna do this i'm
gonna do this i'm going to go out on a
quest and try and find all these
properties
and watching you secure lease option
agreements testimonies about security
agreements and i just thought how would
someone
why would they give up their house but
it makes so much sense yeah
but when i think about the landlady and
the fact that she wants her rent to go
down she wants her mortgage to go down
she doesn't want a headache and being a
landlord i get it as well
like it's no headache for her i get to
manage it i get to profit off of it
but then also being a landlord now when
i'm buying properties i'm realizing
i wouldn't mind somebody taking on my
house and giving me a guaranteed
set amount of money that i didn't have
to worry about whether tenants come or
go
i get that now but i didn't get it
before before this journey so lease
option agreements are
super possible super possible what were
you saying to somebody that was watching
this that was thinking
i want to do a lease option agreement i
want to stop buying lots of houses i
haven't necessarily got the capital to
start up how do i follow in your
footsteps
oh my goodness i think the best advice
samuel's ever given me and actually i
was speaking to my mom about this the
other day
um the best advice he's given me
is get out there yeah like
get out there like you don't know you
don't know until
you go and see all the properties and
view all the properties you do not know
what's going to fall on your lap this
fell on my this
this was viewed such a long time before
it was actually purchased
so i would just say go for it you can
secure lease options you can secure rent
to rent you can find
development projects you can find
amazing hmos and add value to them like
it's all for the taking but you have to
go out there you can educate yourself
but
if you don't go out there and actually
physically do the work
yeah that's the biggest thing in other
words stop just watching youtube videos
yeah
yeah yeah and actually get amongst
people
meet people view properties come to the
crash you you came to the crash course
in 2014.
yes yeah what would you say to someone
thinking about coming to the crowd you
were the first ever person
i was okay okay guys i was the first
ever person of this crash course okay
this is what makes me so motivated i'm
so gassed okay
because i was the first person at the
crash course like seven years ago
and there was eight of us in the room
literally
and there was samuel was on a laptop
okay like teaching
us about financial freedom all right
there wasn't all these courses or
anything it was just about financial
freedom
and years later after i became
financially free i went to that same
crash course but instead of being eight
of us there's like 800 people a thousand
people
a thousand people in the room and a
massive screen
with the same teachings but on a bigger
screen with more information man
that's the biggest drive for me because
i've seen his growth
so if you are looking to go to the crash
course
honest to god your life will change so
long as you believe it as long as you
put the education
the work into it and you're confident
and ready to go
the crash course the courses will guide
you to the next level the next part of
your evolution
it definitely did my life has changed my
life has changed
literally and you you know what let me
tell you something the property investor
crash course i'm going to be teaching
lease option agreements maybe you'll see
jl there jl tends to come down to the
crash courses
rocks up you know what's your strongest
reason for doing this
always my son um absolutely my son um
but then my second strongest thing is
people is is is giving people
the tools and the being an example
for people to be able to be financially
free and to be able to be comfortable
and just live a good life
right so live a good life for your son
to not only help but inspire your son
but you mentioned about to be able to
inspire other people
let me say something that's why i do
this people say something if you if
you're making millions of pounds in
property
doing lease option agreements on land
and making a hundred grand their hundred
grand that all
why you keep doing youtube videos
telling everybody but it's because
actually part of my mission
part of my joy and part of my
satisfaction is seeing people like jl
and others i mean i've interviewed
hundreds of people on my channel who
have become financially free from the
exact same training that jl's doing
so that's part of my satisfaction it's
great to do business with jl
and i hope to see you real soon on the
crash course so get booked on don't
hesitate
get booked on link in the description
and i'll personally see you there
final words of wisdom never give up
yeah never give up love that all right
guys peace out subscribe i'll see you
all soon
[Music]
i've got the keys it's controlled by one
of my students
namely tom thomas how old are you tom
he's
18 years old he shops up here there's
apartments above them
these apartments have these they've got
multiple rooms and that means that we
can do rent to rent on those rooms
i'm paying the landlord 575 for
to control the property yeah and then
the rent that i'm getting a month
comes to about 1 500 pounds
and above the commercial building
there's two blocks of flats
that's all owned by the same landlord
and one of my students hendrix
he's actually secured this direct to
landlord on a red to rent basis
he'll be making him around about 1
900 pounds a month profit
[Music]